41. now we've been talking today about
the government's plans to level up
england and other parts of the united
kingdom this is mostly about handing
power and money down from whitehall to
towns and communities around the country
and are in my opinion today fits in
really well with the question of how to
tackle inequalities let me introduce you
to gary stevenson a trader economist and
a self-made millionaire hello gary how
are you
hi i'm okay thanks you're someone who
grew up i think in the southeast right
so are you an essex boy is that right
uh i'm from illford which uh soldier for
some debate
[Laughter]
right so how are you aware of these
level of these um sort of regional
inequalities and the leveling up issues
that are around and we've been talking
about
well i mean i've been i'm an inequality
economist i mean my background is i
worked in the city in 2008 and um
i saw a crisis where the rich got
enormously richer and ordinary people
did pretty badly and um i made my money
by betting on the fact that because we
wouldn't do anything about inequality
ordinary people would struggle and the
economy would be very weak for a long
time so you know i know that if we don't
deal with inequality which again is
exploding now we'll have a very weak
economy for a long long time so putting
it very simply you made a lot of money
betting on the fact that our economy
would stay unequal and the wealthy would
get wealthier
not just unequal but that our economy
would would be very very weak for a long
time because if the money sits in the
pocket of millionaires and billionaires
while ordinary people get poorer
then you will not have an economic
stimulus you're not an economic boom all
you will see is stock prices and house
prices go through the roof which is
exactly what we've seen so you were
there working in the city 2008
fast forward to now 2022 what are you
seeing what parallels are you seeing
with the way that the economy has been
managed through the pandemic
the parallels are unbelievable i mean
it's like deja vu all over again and
it's a nightmare to be honest so you
know the kovitz crisis was a disaster
for ordinary people but it saw the
biggest ever increase in billionaire
wealth in the history of this country
can you explain how that happened i i
think a lot of people have heard that
but don't quite understand it well
basically you know the economy went on
freeze but the problem is under a normal
economy very rich people make an
enormous amount of income from their
wealth but that comes from ordinary
workers but if ordinary workers can't
work then they can't pay any money to
the rich because the rich aren't
spending any money
so when the government pumped loads of
money into the economy
the rich were still making their income
but they weren't spending any money and
they accumulated an enormous amount the
average billionaire accumulated 700
million pounds university of kobet
i mean those kinds of figures are
eye-watering and way bigger than any of
the money that we're talking about being
invested in various different leveling
up projects right what is the answer to
all of this you've got a plan
yeah it has to be a wealth tax you know
at the moment we have a tax system which
is very very effective at taxing
ordinary working people you know i'm
sure you pay your fair share of tax when
you work i paid mine but very wealthy
people who get their income from wealth
rather than work tend to pay extremely
low rates of tax because they don't pay
normal income tax it's capital gains
it's trusts they have lower rates of tax
and they can be more easily avoided so
currently we have a tax system where
ordinary people pay very high rates of
tax i paid more than 50 on everything i
made but wealthy people pay almost
nothing if you have this system it is
inevitable that wealth will flow up the
rich will get massively richer which
they are doing ordinary families will
get poorer and the economy will be
weaker we need to shift taxes to wealth
we need to bring in a wealth tax and how
would that wealth tax actually work
well the first thing to do is to make
clear the difference between wealth and
income right i come from an ordinary
family i know that for most ordinary
families money is about your job money
is about income that's not how very
wealthy families work okay they own
enormous amounts of assets that's
companies buildings lands property
and they get their income from that
wealth okay so it's about the amount of
wealth that you own ordinary people
probably just own a house if they're
lucky but wealthy people own hundreds of
millions of pounds worth of assets it's
about looking at the wealth that you own
and saying you need to pay a percentage
of that back because it's important to
realize that these guys make money from
their wealth and that money comes from
us but at the moment they're not paying
anything back so it's about not looking
just at work at income by looking at
these families small amount of families
have accumulated huge amounts of wealth
and saying look we can't let you
continue sucking wealth out of society
you have to start paying tax not just on
your income which often they don't pay
but on the wealth that you own as well
but this could draw in potentially more
you know
ordinary people for one of a better term
who happen to have sat in a house over
three or four decades that's massively
increased in value if you're talking
about a wealth tax on assets of a
million pounds
yeah i mean the first thing to say is
you know the most important thing is
that the super super rich get taxed
that's the most important thing but you
know i got called up for this program
and they said you know what kind of
level would you be comfortable with and
look the truth is you know i've been
very open about it i'm a millionaire but
i'm not super rich you know i'm not
rishi sonak who has an estimated worth
of 200 million pounds and if i say look
let's come in and start a tax at 10
million pounds well that's not going to
affect me but what i'm saying is i'm
willing to contribute i'm willing to
contribute i'm willing to pay more and i
think the wealthy people of this country
would be willing to pay more if it was
going to improve the economy of this
country but the most important thing is
if people like me are going to pay
people who are millionaires but not
super rich then they're super super rich
like richie sonic and jacob rees-mogg
have to pay too and it's about fixing
the economy of this country how do you
pay a tax on a house if you're not
selling it
well i mean there are many ways you can
do it you know you can you can take
loans out on that house if you if your
wealth is into 10 hundreds of millions
of pounds you should be able to easily
raise cash but there's a few economists
who have looked at this there's aaron
advani there's gabriel zuckerman
basically you know they say the
government can take a small percentage
ownership share you know if we're
talking about people with wealth of 10
20 even 100 million pounds they can
afford to pay some percentage of that
back and there's various ways of doing
it they can borrow against it or the
government can take small shares of
ownership you know better than me right
the laffer curve which basically says
that the higher you tax people there is
a point at which you then start to
accrue less or fewer tax receipts you
don't get as much back because i guess
simply but ultimately very rich people
will
find ways to protect their assets from
taxation that's the problem isn't it yes
i mean that question has been bouncing
around for a bit this idea about the
laffer curve that's about income taxes
and you know it's been contested the
idea but the idea is if you were to have
a 100 tax on income well people wouldn't
work right you wouldn't work if you're
going to lose all of your income from it
but we're not talking about income here
we're talking about wealth the whole
idea is we want to move wealth away from
wealthy people towards ordinary families
okay and you know if you had a 100 tax
your income you could say well i'm
stopping working but if you have a high
tax on your wealth well what are you
going to do you're going to give your
wealth away well that's what we want we
want ordinary families to get their
wealth back you know that is the whole
reason why we need to tax wealth because
it's less avoidable because they can't
stop holding it let me read some
reaction because you're getting lots get
this man on more please he's absolutely
spot on can we make this guy chancellor
this man is fab this man speaks the
truth at long last it's on the radio
this one here your caller on wealth tax
is talking tosh assets of one million
including a house does not mean you have
money or earn a huge salary many people
have worked all their lives and still
not retired that are on a normal salary
that would be penalized unfairly
it's utter rubbish says sean
yeah you know to be honest i'm very sort
of understanding of that the truth is
the way that house prices have gone
especially in southeastern london over
the last 10 15 years there are a lot of
people who have lived relatively
ordinary lives who have not been super
rich who are now millionaires because of
what has happened to house prices and
it's important to make clear look these
guys are not the problem really it's not
the the well ordinary millionaires it's
important to say a million pounds is a
lot of money these guys not the problem
really the problem is the super rich and
if you were to say to me look let's come
in at five ten million and only get the
really really rich i would buy your hand
off and say let's do that but what i'm
saying is look i'm happy to pay two and
i wouldn't be talking about any sort of
really significant taxes on people above
a million pounds because you know
now in a lot of parts of the country
that amount of money is only enough to
buy you a house basically but um
what i'm saying is that i'm not super
rich but i'm a millionaire i'd be happy
to i mean i should say i should keep
saying that you are super rich compared
to most people in this country well that
makes it super rich
you know a million pounds is 200 times
less than what you've seen a thousand
times less than his father
very very few people very nice people i
can buy like one nice house in london
but richardson i can buy 200. okay and i
i should say to be fair across the board
no political party has ever gone for
this not the conservatives and not
labour they've not got anywhere close to
raising the sorts of money you're
talking about yeah you know it's
interesting you say that but if you go
back and look at sort of the 50s and 60s
which i generally consider to be the
golden era of capitalism we had much
much higher rates of tax on wealth you
know what i mean it was much more
difficult to hold huge amounts of wealth
and to accumulate and hold it within
families and what was the case at that
time houses cost two to three times
income there were lots of good jobs it
was generally considered to be a time
that was that was great to be alive
economically you know what i mean um i
don't think it's a coincidence that now
we've stopped taxing wealth and we've
moved to a situation where the rich are
getting richer and richer and richer the
house price is going up and inflation's
going up you know at the beginning of
kobe i put a video out on my youtube
channel gary's economics saying look the
rich are going to get massively richer
here that's going to massively increase
inequality house prices and inflation
and it's happened you know what i mean
if you allow the rich to get richer
that's what will happen house prices
inflation are going to go through the
roof we need to do something about it
garen really enjoyed listening to your
arguments this morning i know people
will um
you know agree and some will disagree
and and that's what we like it's
provoked a reaction and got us thinking
in a slightly different way thank you
for coming on and talking to us
thank you all the best gary stevenson
trader economist millionaire himself as
he said but not super rich as he said so
what do you think about all of that
as i've already mentioned loads of you
sharing your thoughts 85058 send us a
voice note via whatsapp 08085 909
693 if you want to have your say like
gary it's 7 52.